Caravaggio has been remembered by
history as a mad violent dangerous
outsider but what people often forget is
that he was a violent man but he was a
violent man in a violent world and he
followed its rules he maybe was more
extreme than some other people but you
have to think what Rome was like you
know in in the late 16th and early 17th
century and Caravaggio lived there the
church is in a state of crisis desperate
for art artists are flocking to the city
hundreds of artists thousands of artists
it's it's like Hollywood except there's
only one studio in town and that tap
that that that studio is is is the
Vatican
so it's this magnet for artists magnet
for clerics magnet for mercenaries
magnet for pilgrims magnet for paupers
and beggars
it's a testosterone-fueled city being
serviced by a vagrant commuting a
community of prostitutes this place full
of disorder full of arguments full of
fights full of rivalry full of hostility
and the whole thing is governed by this
code of honor that's slightly analogous
to the kind of codes of honor that you
get among gangs in modern cities you
looking at me it's that kind of thing a
lot of Caravaggio's fights are all
basically about you looking at me what
are you saying about me you know waiter
serves him a plate of artichokes the
artichokes have butter on them so
Caravaggio smashes the plate in the
waiters face cuts his face sends into
hospital we know this because the weight
of them complains to a judge sues
Caravaggio and we have the records in
the Roman archive of of the trial
Caravaggio gets off because he has
powerful friends in high places but we
know what's behind this fight with
artichokes Caravaggio is from Lombardi
which is in northern Italy the waiter is
from Rome
the waiter thinks that artichokes should
be served with olive oil
so does Caravaggio actually but the
waiter thinks Caravaggio is from not
he's a cheese eating Vulgarian so he
serves them it's like saying you're not
welcome here so racial insult served up
as a dish and things are always like
that in rim these little insults that
are going on all the time and Caravaggio
is super sensitive to anything like that
so he's always getting into trouble the
only way to get on as an artist in this
cutthroat deeply competitive world was
to make friends with the right people
you had to have high up friends if you
tried to as it were
get to the top via the back route you
know working your way up through an
artist's studio becoming his assistant
as apprentice eventually getting us to
you'd be there forever forget it what
you have to do is you have to have a
powerful friend and Caravaggio very
cleverly he's living on the street he
has no money is this dark dangerous
Valley bond character getting into
trouble getting into fights he's blessed
with this great genius for painting but
he can't quite get himself to where he
needs to be he has the good fortune to
make friends with a guy called
costantino sparta who's a picture dealer
he's got like five kids to feed needs
money between them they hatch a plan so
in the palace opposite costantino
sputters shop lives the cardinal del
Monte who's a bit of an avant-garde
collector collects new music is very
interested in new music was very
interested in new kinds of art and
spatter and Caravaggio dream up a new
kind of painting so genre painting is
now called it's now an established kind
of art but then it wasn't it was a new
kind of painting and what it what they
painted what sputter persuaded
Caravaggio to paint was scenes from
Modern Life two scenes in particular two
card sharps fooling a young man out of
his money and a gypsy fortune-teller
picking a young man's pocket as she
charmed him of her beautiful eyes and
her beautiful face as she pretends to
terminus fortune and these two pictures
it worked the trick worked
del Monte went into the shop and said
who painted these
these are incredible said oh it's a
bloke I know called Caravaggio del Monte
buys the pictures and the next thing you
know Caravaggio is living in the Palazzo
madama he's been taken in he's become
one of Del Monte's protégées Del Monte
is a remarkable man he's he supports the
writing of the very first opera
he's Galileo's principal patron he's the
man who introduces Galileo to the Medici
so in a sense he's responsible for some
of the great breakthroughs in modern
science because without his support
Galileo might never have made it so
suddenly Caravaggio has has got into the
Cardinals palace and once he's got there
he's he's on the way up he's got his
foot on the first rung of the ladder
that's probably the pivotal moment of
his of his early career